we really like being family entrepreneurs
in the second generation and are continuing the
company and transforming it,
but now to
bring our own brand onto the road and
to take on the role of founder that is
what really drove us there
and yes, that's why we think so  it also like
its own brand and do
exactly what you said,
influenza marketing socially paid and all
the things to get the brand on the street
and trade in baby products, so
you sell prams what do
you even earn with a
franchise  -Concept like Baby one
does the people make a quarter of a
billion in sales primarily with
franchise baby products and they want to expand
expand their own baby stroller or stroller invent
your new brand launch everything is
discussed with Anna and Jan  Are you going
to be a guest? Anna Weber and Jan are whiter
and you own Bibi or
that's true and correct hit you
somehow inherited it from
your father
exactly we are the second generation
our parents have run the company for
almost 30 years and for
two years  we are completely alone at the
helm and was it already foreseeable when
you yourself were teenagers or
students that one day you
wouldn't take over that at all, so
we didn't plan
to take over the company at some point
but went into completely different
jobs ourselves  and we
had our own experiences and then
at some point we were like that when we
had our first children too.
Okay, somehow
the job in a corporate environment is not quite
the right thing and let's
see what our parents have built up there
and then we
approached them ourselves, okay, together, no,
actually separate from each other, but
relatively parallel because we were both in
a very similar situation at the same time,
we talked to our parents
and then it came out, ah look,
your sister is talking to
us too and then we met  but too much
put together then there are other
siblings yes we have other
siblings that means there are four of us
and the other two aren’t even
in the company we do
n’t want each other either and we also do something completely
different and the company comes from
that  your father just always
when you had the idea or
I think he was a franchisee himself or
how it went exactly originally
our father inherited a lot of
toys from his father
so we grew up
with the game of trading goods and at
some point he stopped  realized that
four children and a dog could no longer be financed with
a stationary toy store
and then he got together in an
experience-sharing group that was involved in the game
and thought about what
we can do
Our father then became the first
franchisee for
strollers, baby items, no matter
what, we are actually
a full-range supplier of organic toddler
equipment. We actually have
everything you need from birth to the
age of four, that means
we have we have pacifiers we have
Bottles we have prams we
have car seats we have textiles
we have toys that means everything
except consumables no food
no diapers okay and that means your
father started back then and erm then
realized it’s going quite well which
game instructions do I have a baby
load and  he opened up more exactly
the founder of BabyOne unfortunately
died very young and our father
then bought the company and
became the managing director and owner. I
think when he took over
there were around 20 stores and then
we grew really fast
now 103 stationary specialist stores and
online
that means our parents made it big did
n't really
found it our mother then
went in and then the
two of them ran it for years and now you own
all this data or do you still have
many franchise  Partnerinnen
Two thirds of us are franchise partners, so
notice that they are run by franchise partners,
we have very
different sizes, there are
franchise partners who have ten stores, there
are many who have one store and we
run a third of the stores ourselves
and  you can also read all about it
makes about a quarter of a billion in
sales, right, and now your goal is
to make that happen,
so we're, uh, we're a
family business and now I
think we've got the billion, that's definitely going to take,
uh, growth market
definitely because  there are more and more children
or I wouldn't actually now
demographically no it's not no no
children out right now no
it's not we've always had
constant such a small growth
being offered for our last
year is a big slump at the
point but still  is the topic of children
and also what people spend on their children what
they invest that is
definitely a growing market at the
point but you are not
alone either, there are definitely
market companions similar to the ones in the
hardware stores, the colleagues recently became
Obi
seemed to me to be from a similar
market so you had a
cover like that and then you have to have a radius and
if you're not careful then the
next one opens up everything at the edge but it
doesn't have to be absolutely that can always
happen and that's why it's natural
also a lot of cut-throat competition, no, we
have other big competitors, but there
are also a great many regional
individual players in the market
and there is definitely still
potential, you baby market Baby Walz
exactly, so those are the ones that
do a really very similar business to us,
exactly  and then of course
many others will come into the market
if we now look at drugstores
or discounters that
also cover part of our range and then of course
the big platform
amazon also has everything, of course,
but okay and how much business there is
you online
you mean percentage of sales
we are now at about 17 percent okay
that we do online in the last few
years before Corona
we were not even at 5 percent
online sales
so I mean stationary is still a
bit different but that's okay
On the other hand, you always have to step in,
not even in all of our areas,
i.e. these super
advice-intensive stroller
car seats and even if you go in medium and
high price, Amazon is not
necessarily our competitor, but there
are also simply ranges that are still
bought a lot in stationary stores  and to be
honest, online was
absolutely not in focus for us before Corona but now
but you would think that it’s more
online that’s out of the generation
would drive it massively would also drive it independently
of Corona omni channel we definitely so
we go absolutely
Assuming that the networking of
online and offline is our huge
added value, with the branch network that we
have in Germany, Austria and
Switzerland, more than 100 markets, we can
advise the customer regionally and there are
surveys that more than 80 percent
of all purchases in our
Having a stationary touchpoint somewhere in this area
means that people get advice in the
shops at some point
most of them are there whether the customer
buys online or in the stationary
shop, we don’t care at all because we
cover both and because we always use the channels
better interlocking but
finding branches network is still
a big USB in me
definitely okay so if
someone wants to listen came
call you for a license or a franchise
then look for people who
want to build up this franchise-storfell
would definitely be us  completely open
to and then it's always about
finding a good location because we simply
have a high level of coverage, but there are
still a few white spots and
we really want to fill them in.
definitely a lot of white spots in southern Germany
that's because the
purchasing power in southern Germany
is a lot higher again and
of course we look at purchasing power,
birth rates and all that, so in
southern Germany there is a lot and where
is we stationary not much there
is more in the east around Chemnitz
Erfurt we are not there yet
but it is  super high potential so
inviting you can make a good living from it
you can make a good living from it you can make a
better living from it if you have two or three
markets
there we are always on average
our lives because around 2 million euros in
sales and then 20%
of that remains  would be nice
almost so if you prepare that
three to five percent get stuck the
three five yes and there are also shops where
more get stuck is then always
a question which yes is running what kind of
rental agreement do you have a huge
factor and what do you do
in Chemnitz and erm I'm in the mood for it
then I was up a shop with you then
embarrassingly then somehow after a
certain ramp-up phase 2 million
sales and then I can
look forward to that then but
100000 as an
annual income then get stuck
Salary you can  Of course, you can
also pay out in parallel beforehand and then
you can definitely get to that
size. It's about the same for you in the
entire group, so if
you somehow get 250 million of them,
about 5% get stuck in the
whole group, so what gets stuck
there  are we in a region where we do
n't talk about it completely transparently
because of course it will be there too, we were
really aware of individual ones,
then as a franchise system we
naturally also have the franchise headquarters where the
franchise fee goes in etc.,
let's say entrepreneurial factors  Lead time is much bigger
than I won't be surprised
if there should be more otherwise
you can give a little bit so if
or
good try but
at the end of the day it's really a
size where we say okay we rely
on transparency extremely but work  we
really go there and erm then
it's really yes, actually, because
we are of course also the ones who are
central in many places who say how to
invest properly in the future and
accordingly that is also what we are
firmly convinced that our
system is on the right track  The way is
simply also requires that
if we want to continue being that, it was
simply taking money into our hands and
investing what are the main
areas of investment so
much it a lot IT new
systems improve systems replace systems and
set them up more flexibly definitely and at the
moment definitely that too  The topic of
own brands is something new to tackle and that
's also an
investment spirit but okay and I
would say the third big point is
definitely personnel, so that's where
we invest the most in the headquarters
new competencies skills that we simply did
n't have before  because we did
n't have to occupy the fields
to educate people further and so I'm now on
and to bring new people to us at all
exactly and I assume that you can
now just release about
25 million about 10% a year
from which you can then invest
you manage  So that's
kind of a family business
with such a subordinate,
um,
or is there always
a partner to look for, or is that possible on your own? It's
complex and
reorganizing the group online with everything that goes
along with it, what sort of
things do you need  So that's why
we're going, of course we're
not super super fast because we
invest entirely from the cash flow and also sit in new fields
and do it alone and not
with an investor who we get in
because the company is still one hundred
percent our family  should belong and
yes it is possible is over but
certainly not possible as quickly
as the investors finance
the startups can do but
investors will still knock on your door and,
for example,
really really want to buy parts and then buy
the company completely right
there  no interest in why
not
see more value in the fact that this
is a family-run company and what
we can do to
focus on sustainable growth at the
same time as making decisions quickly in many places
we don't want to give that up and we are
convinced that we can  are
your competitors are also all in the
same family, some of whom have
investors,
so they would like to do this famous
rollup, focus on the market
and then see that you then somewhere
then
we don't have any specific
offers yet  so this is
all hypothetical now but in our market
we are the only family run
okay and does one worry sometimes
that one is so paranoid that one will
rate how the next 10 years or is
my 10%
guess so bad and it was  stop
being 30%
we have the self-confidence
of course uh let's take a look at it and
uh then see the topic of
loss carryforwards that we see and if
sometimes maybe a bit
jealous that we don't have the same
funds but we also see ourselves as well
and stably positioned  and so big
that we say we'll get on
our way, so in the
end it also depends very much on
the producers or is there
so many different producers or
isn't at my mercy in the end,
so I think that  whenever
I somehow see buddies who
have sneakers like that, they just need
the decisive sneakers from Adidas
or the location is trailer is like that or
from Nike if they don't get it then
it's totally difficult
or not clear definitely that's why
we work too  a lot and intensively with
our different manufacturers
but there are very, very
many of them in our market, of course there are
some that the focus is on, but
the range of products is already huge
and therefore the rule is also manufacturer-wide
and I don’t think you can
quite do it with sneakers  compare because
brands are important in our business
but honestly when do you get to know these
brands at the time when you
find out where you are going to get pregnant
or where your wife is going to get pregnant then
the first touchpoint is that you
find out about the brands at all and
beforehand  don't you even notice it
and whether the brand is called XY or whatever, that
's a lot of
consulting work and that's why
I don't think the brands have
such a huge importance as in the sneaker market, okay, but
that's what the brands are like without them
not against Burger BU or what's that
where you can no longer
clearly
big brands Bugaboo Cybex Joey Maxi
Cosi the Maxi Cosi the Maxi Cosi exactly that's
almost a category concept ne
Maxi Cosi built up in German company nee
Dutch is
the one behind it or no  that's the name of the company
and
they're not probably completely
burnt have managed to put a new
product on and that's called
Maxi Cosi everywhere and everyone knows what's
meant so it's definitely
so that a few years ago there were
many, many more families  managed
companies at our manufacturers
we have
a main fair in our group
that runs in Cologne once a year the
children and youth and I
still remember when we were there with our father for the first time,
he went through it
and actually was  it was like a big
family reunion because he
went to the seniors everywhere and we were there
as children and the other children
of the entrepreneurs were there too and I
think that the majority of them
have actually sold parts or all of them to investors, so that’s why it
happened there too  a lot of market
I mean so what are there actually
category
we are now going completely new with a new
own brand in the area of ​​prams
oh you have
your own pram exactly that will be available
from April also in the
Bugaboo segment or he  cheaper or technically
different or
is in any case
a bit lower in price
will be at 899 euros as an RRP and in terms of
design and quality under the
functions but overshadows everything
that is
natural and who is doing it, so
retail now suddenly has to
become a producer themselves  means how are things going
you drive around the world and
look at where can I have the pram
built or do you then hire
the craftsmen or how does it work
exactly we actually started two years ago
with the fact that we
said we wanted a new private label
we already have our own brands, yes,
with a small proportion, definitely
less than ten percent, and these are
all white label solutions, which means we did
n't actually do much to it in product development and
then we set out and
said we wanted another one  Do a little more
and we have to expand our own brands
and also want to get a little
more involved in the economic chain
so that we can of course also tap into more margin at the end of the
day
and then we looked at what kind of product we made said
baby carriages
and then we started  We also
approached production facilities but at
the same time approached our partners
and our suppliers
said you would like to do something with us
in order to be transparent right from the start and at
the same time we put together a completely new team and
got know-how about what we had before  to
then simply develop a good
product, so and
suppliers were also relaxed, so
when you say okay, by the way, uh, we
also want to build it ourselves,
so it's not like everyone says
it's great,
no, but we were there from the start
completely transparent
no one was really surprised our
suppliers also gradually opened their own D2C shops
and
understood our way and
whether they were super enthusiastic
is of course another
story but we also
invited everyone to take part
in the production facility  in China that
was simply at the end of the day the
best quality there were the fastest possible
reactions there was
almost 85% of all strollers are
also built there that means you determine
the design and the look and
and
differentiate but of course the price only
in the end  first of all it looks super
cool so design was super
important to us functionality so that means
it looks super cool in Berlin
Prenzlauer Berg but has all the functions
that you can use in the forest and everywhere
are one-hand mechanisms you
can fold the tub together with one hand
lose weight in one hand, there is
a huge basket, so all the
functions that are important to you as a parent are
in there and then we have also
put great emphasis on quality and durability, which means we also give a
lifetime guarantee on the car because
we carry out all kinds of tests  ten years
and not just
five that is standard for prams
and finally also
completely passed the point of sustainability so
the materials contain 100% recycled
materials in the fabrics 30%
in the hard plastic pieces so we
really made sure that  we are also going to
bring a sustainably good product onto the market then somehow Kinder
was more or less stable in value than I think.
I have the feeling you need them for
a few years and actually there should be a
huge
secondary market place for prams so
that you can buy defective new ones
should actually take a while  being an exception
is still a large part that is
really only bought because
I think it is somehow part of the first child
is an event you people
often go to the market again with their parents
and the grandparents
pay for the stroller but all that
for the first child you often want to
have the best somehow okay and
then he gets the second child from the first
child yes and then they are resold yes
not of course they will be
resold no so there is a
huge secondary market of course via the
official channels such as ebay
classified ads  or mamikreisel but
of course can also be tracked in two
recycling
Jan family drove my pram
and never bought one themselves
the channels can't
follow any further so it exists and
you can see from that that a pram
is well made and durable
is also a sustainability in
itself, but where are all the
old prams, I mean the
old cars, you know, some of them are driving
around in Africa or something and
our German cars or somehow
I don’t know somewhere in the
Middle East or something  I think
a lot of cars are exported to where are
all the prams from
people who are 30 today whose
prams are going, so I would say quite
a lot are in our specialist stores in
the
live pram department we have
one last week in Villingen in
ours  Market have really discovered a huge
stock of old prams that
have never been picked up and what they
like prams that go out when
something on the pram itself
is broken and needs to be repaired,
so you always get a so if
something is broken on your pram
then you get it  you are of course
provided by our prams or something
prams
is a word but no we don't offer there are
suppliers but we are
not yet active in the market what are
the products most often
through
the best
e
where the
best margin would be  I say we are in the
textile sector, so textiles
we actually always have a good
brand, then somehow these
rompers or something in the exactly yes and
and baby carriages are not even thought of
at the price but good production why
is mainly so big
because we with the  new private label
we have also decided that we
really want to create a new brand that
is not immediately recognizable as our own brand and simply
has its own appeal and in order to build a new
brand we simply need
a
strong product in our industry and as we said it is there  the
pram is often the product that is
bought first what everyone wants
when expecting a child and the
private label is called like your own children
ne crazy ne so we say Emil and
and
these are your families, so to speak, the
firstborn and born okay okay
is one of the whole
now we just take the name if
you like it anyway and it's easy to
remember and we're going to make a
brand out of it to become exactly the names of his
children we'll just take the brand like
that then we'll forget it so
how do you get that so easy  so
during the brainstorming at some point it was
the idea exactly we
thought about what we can use as a brand
and just got to the point
that we can also make a statement with it
that is that the thing
is really important to us and that we can use
it  We can also show that it is
important to us that the thing is of top quality,
that the um sustainability
sets a new standard and accordingly
we decided to do it and there will be but
no only need
and on parental allowance and in ours
it is a bit different the playbook
what  As you have seen, there are now
some children's products that are really blatantly
successful, so I've had
the tonies on
another one of these bikes for the last few years  even
worse than
when I see what my brother
is doing now, so that's
the Ferrari, but it's also
really expensive, but also the product, no matter
what you ask, so say you need the
stroller, so if that attacks you then
you can do it yourself
Maybe build a company with a turnover of several 100
million,
we also believe that we can definitely
get something and what we have just
learned about the Baby one system
is the know-how about what the customers
really want from the stroller, so
these are things that  we have studied for months
and not only based on
KPIs and pay, but above all
also based on the
salespeople in our stores we
have made a call for tenders
and have founded a cupcreation team
which has been around for about a year now
and the salespeople
developed this pram together with us and
really said okay you need
that and that has to happen at the bottom of the bar,
the folding mechanism has to
be there, these are the things that the
customers ask about at the basket and we
believe that we do  have
now managed to create a pram that really
fulfills customer needs and that's why
we definitely believe that
we can already rake a lot
in the market from a pram
erm a few thousand well that would be
a good few thousand it's now at
a purchase price of 900  € or something like that,
you make a few million sales in the first year.
Of course, the goal always has to be
that we
factor in a different margin, we
sell it to BabyOne first and then
it's sold on, but that's
a little bit for you  left pocket
and a bit yes in the markets that
we run ourselves and otherwise
we're of course there to strengthen the drum space one
system at that point too
and say okay that's
the maximum cost and then also
argued about the magic and stuff  so
what may cost no we do
n't talk about it that's an EIA at the end of the day
because that's the nice thing about a
franchise system like this we're all called BabyOne
in the truest sense we're all independent
entrepreneurs that means we're
not allowed to talk about sales prices and
otherwise there are  of course there will be discussion
and they will look at the product and, of
course, also say whether it
is good or bad, but the nice thing
is that we are all convinced
that we need a strong private label
and accordingly everyone is
behind what we do and it is  the
version of the topic, above all,
the markets in the roof, it is with the
product with the competence could still
easily be set up, I imagine
Holland Scandinavia not
going to Poland, we can well imagine something
that is not super easy because
in  other countries, for example when it
comes to Scandinavian countries,
they have completely different requirements, for
example when it comes to prams, they
have a much larger carrycot in the
pram because the children are
in there for much longer, well beyond the
age of one and that is
in Germany, for example  Not at all, so
you would also need
different purchasing skills and all that and
it is not our focus right now because
we simply do not want to do so much in parallel to
extend and or deepen our focus value chain
and
build up our own brands and online, so to speak,
but that’s true  with the stroller,
we also took a very close
look at that, so Amazon is in a
completely different price segment than the children
sell because of that, so we do
n’t believe that the Amazon
range is more or less on Amazon
how do you argue that
people then buy from you  and online
and not at Amazon
we definitely don't have to be decisive online
otherwise we can't
have any importance online if we
can communicate the price of course
it must be our goal to always be
able to keep up with the price overall we do
n't have to be price leaders, hell
come out of it  Prices are depressing
but if we are over there in terms of price
and that also applies to our
specialist stores if we had the exorbitantly
more expensive prices then we would have
no
meaning at all towards the customer who
should we tell that he
should buy from us how big is the
radius  about an existing baby shop
that you can open a new one
so we actually always calculate the
route no we do analyzes about the
route and we say that a customer
drives about 45 minutes
to get to the market and actually there
isn’t even that
Of course, we have area protection for franchise markets,
so where no other
franchisees can enter,
but we also have other regions where
we are totally consolidating and where that
makes sense, here in Hamburg, for
example, there are five because it makes
total sense  does and because I do
n't think it would take 45 minutes to get to a market in Hamburg
either, no, you need
a much shorter way to get there, but in the
country people sometimes drive 45 minutes, which
means you have to know the region
exactly  and that's why it makes
so much sense to work with the entrepreneur on site
who knows that, who knows whether this is
the wrong or the right
corner of Lübeck, which
can be connected by bus in one way or another
and where there is a good connection  is it so it
is totally different
look at where the competition is
or or do you then consciously go next to
the competition there is that okay
here is a bakery that is doing well
or was that i experienced it earlier erm well then there
was a classic bakery
Somehow a bakery came like a
fast train or even back on itself
service chain okay that's great there
it's running so the right next to it then knows
that's enough traffic is because I
'm cheaper zack works so
you think more like that he thinks okay we
have to somehow spots  where there
isn't one,
so I think we prefer to find
spots where there isn't one yet, but
of course there are fewer and fewer of those, we
're not afraid
to go near a competitor,
but I think we really
have to position ourselves right next to it  I do
n't and at the end of the day
yes that goes into the calculation how
much do we expect we can
pick up on it and of course it depends on
how many competitors are in the vicinity
and that then all flows in
is a good location and why in general
he doesn't do it anymore  Toys When I
think about something, it's probably
pretty frustrating
to be a child dealer or baby dealer first of all because the time is
manageable, maybe you're lucky
and then the
customer's life cycle extends a bit
when the next child comes, but
we still look at it at most then
because I don't as a family normally
eight years ten years when
the customers might need their products and
then the children are a bit older and
then actually not anymore and then
the family is through you never see each other
again so where you customers 100 although you
maybe has a customer contact it's like
that, so we actually assume
a lot less, namely a
maximum of four years in the customer
life cycle because most of us
really buy for the first child and
most of it happens even worse exactly
that I just say how it shows
That means that most of the purchases
actually happen with us in
the first 30 days and that is before the
birth even ne the big purchases
are made before the birth and then of
course you also have something like
car seats that you buy again
because you simply when the children
get older you will need car seats for a long time
a few textiles and
toys, which in our case
are more like articles by name and
[music]
of course we also know that there are also
competitors of ours who are now also
using older children  but it's really
a different business model there's
also a reason why our father
stopped making toys they
just don't know are good mornings either erm and I know it was
n't worth it and we
said we'd stay with the
customer group that we're really good at
and  This is
not the case for pregnant women and babies up to 4 years of age and more and they try to
tap more of the market in this area and grow in this way and
not over the structure of older children
and what we offer is
a point that hardly anyone else can offer
can offer in the intensity is that we
are representable in many places
and can offer really good advice
and then that means that the customers come to
us, of course, above all because
of products that require advice, prams,
car seats, something that you didn’t
know before or if that  first child born
maybe that's what I really need now
and then really to be
advised and to be able to
put together this initial equipment
we can simply offer that
we can do really well and we
also have potential to grow further because that's
why advice is so crucial
I mean, on the one hand,
advice is important, on the other
hand, I think that
the mothers or fathers are
often already so deeply involved. They
have a circle of friends from others.
Somehow, I know, I met
people with the birth preparation course
and somehow they have
siblings and they just had children
gotten that you actually
almost know that you want it and it's
maybe too
high-touch when you get ready in the store
but you actually want it
or had read everything in an online shop
that means I would have
thought it would just be enough  would like to pick up um
because the training has
already been done somewhere else is not above a
headphone market or maybe
he says again, ok, let me
get back to you maybe you would rather
let yourself be given away for the headphones um yeah
well we did studies really
crazy that is  fifty fifty ne about
50% of the people seem super well
informed and that is also
a
partial knowledge of what you have
acquired because you
need it at the moment you just like you
say friends and family are the
greatest source of information
then  of course online other online
shops reviews in online shops
test judged also super important above
all on the subject of car seats and 50%
of people come into the market totally rationally and that’s how
50% of people buy
emotionally and there are really
people so we did it ourselves
In the meantime we have
worked in the stores again and again, also in the
advice and people really come
in there, so we need baby buggies we do
n't know anything yet what can we
take,
they have to be picked up, but
the super well-informed people have
to be picked up too, hands and says man  they do
n't even know that we can
sell the expensive model now,
that's the way it should be, in any case, and at
this point what's happening in the market
and how much this advice
means, I can tell you a nice
example, I'm
the second with us  so indecent me with my
wife and then at the same time with
my brother and his partner where
the first children's stand in our
lives went said we'll get
two baby seats here before said
we can take so we do
n't want one but that the margin is too
bad  I think that's stupid so an
hour later we went out with two of
exactly bad marche
because the consultant was so enthusiastic about this
seat that she at least
wrapped the other three completely around her finger and said that's it
and there I am too
The three of them said no,
we have to take it, although in my
opinion it wasn't that good functionally,
but we took two of them and
that's exactly what the advice is about,
so in the end there are
independence and somehow things to
recommend, although  deliver a worse Mario for you,
of course, don’t find that so good, well, but
no, I think you can see what a
power the advice has and the
advice service and our
advisors and advise on the area
will then also be familiar at the moment
and that’s it  Yes, that’s also the important thing,
but then there are also people who are trained by you,
logically, that means
they’ll be made fit by you, that’s
no age now, we’ll
make them fit, of course, they’ll also be made
fit by manufacturers, ne if the
sales representatives drive around but I think
In a shop in Cologne we have
200 different car seats,
you have to be able to
explain them first, that means that
is a high level of expert knowledge and
now we are doing the same for our new own brand for
Elsa and Emil and the pram
through the specialist markets and
schools, the people themselves, that
's a lot of fun, but it makes so
much sense that you also have to do something,
so if you don't look at the franchise headquarters,
we're around 160 people, if you
really look at the whole of Baby One including
markets, we're up to 1400  People with
you yourself or I have to
remember I was with
the Mr. Trigema group
there were there a few months ago, there are also two children such as
a daughter and it's not so
clear because the films take over something
for you somehow  Stress that you
would have to do it for two, so to speak,
but that ever such a question or
what for everyone yes logically the
two do that now there was a group I
mean at group said yes he does
n’t know he has to see first if you
get married if the children get married  whether they
are somehow the right ones, whether they
stay close by and so
when we really
started talking about things I don't
even know how to take a deep breath at the thought that
we work together
how is it like suddenly
working with a family because that's
natural  are very different levels,
but it quickly became clear
that we were going to try it
again,
so five for five years, both
about and our parents are in the early
20 21
not really seen anymore or still
very narrow supervisory board or
are still shareholders and we
meet regularly for
social events and exchange
ideas when we have topics when we say
here tell us we were that again or
how would you do it and otherwise
had left
the office gave us the
order to build on the last day  the offices immediately around
that we did and erm exactly as a
result a picture book
succession and we are also super happy
that our parents
gave us the opportunity and
trust us that we will do it right
now of course they are always strangely
interested
that is also  absolutely right in the
society of the role but how we
do it, how we transform the company,
how we transform it from the business model but above
all culturally
that is completely in
our hands
I already did that recently when
we were working on a project
together with the Sixt company there
are also the sons and the parents
and what I noticed there, which is a
huge advantage is that life is usually
structured in such a way, at least here
in Germany, that when you
are 18 you leave the house
you rarely see your parents or
siblings and
you make your own life and the
family is Christmas and Easter now
you have the chance as an entrepreneur
to do things differently so somehow
okay, so to speak, my family is
important to me, I think  the close ones you
do it together the parents do it
together it's also so that you
really see it as positive that
you say okay I have a chance
to stay with the family and
don't have to move away because of the job
and I don't have a chance at all  if
my family continues to live in that sense,
I think we've always been
super close as a family, I've never
thought about it now whether that was because
our parents were also entrepreneurs and
then somehow built up companies,
so I think we've
always been really close  and we all really like us,
crazy,
and of course it's super intense
every day and I think it's
really cool, I think with
this family spirit and that's also
really important, that's how we
grew up, it's cool professionally
that  you know each other well you can
assess yourself that means you can
get emotional
you just know how to take it
and yes I don't have to
worry about it at all oh what was that
meant now so I know there's someone
who can then  the whole political
blah blah blah no but that's
the other two children aren't in it
you had to pay them out
or how does it work then
that's also
super important in a family business and
also as a parent no you're also what you
as parent verse justice  and of
course our family is also
driven by this and in the process
we know what all this means, especially
with the family no that's not
done by snapping your fingers we are
now the second generation in other
family businesses which are then somehow the
third fourth fifth generation
it's all often already
set out in writing and organized we're
still in the
process of agreeing that if you
work every day yourself
then you get the feeling that I'm growing the
cake and I'm sweating and tears and
someone else might have it  a
little bit less but
maybe it doesn't matter at all um and the little
bit less is always valuable
but because of your work that at
some point you don't find it so funny anymore
and then you think it's
still something like that but he didn't have that no so
we're going to play that now so
that that doesn't happen and that has
n't happened in 20 years,
but that we have a solution for everyone
can put a good tick behind it
very families privately but what's the
mechanics like, what do mechanics do
because there are so many
different possibilities,
really, really many different
possibilities how you
divide company shares, how you
divide other assets, well, that's a
huge colorful bouquet of flowers, how they are
then adjusted again, adjusted and
so everything, well, I think there
are so many endless possibilities
as there are family businesses, okay and
then let's get to it, there is also
special advice
but no, of course not
everything has to be worked out
and so he thinks about specialist lawyers for
Familien
Erb and all these areas of law
if he now makes this new brand, so to speak,
it's also so that we
really want to advertise it properly
outside of the markets, so to speak, in the sense
of influenza, which is now starting to be
bought, then keywords, so then you
really don’t
have to think much about it, absolutely, and that’s
also the super cool thing, so we
really like being family entrepreneurs in the
second generation and continuing the
company and transforming it
but now to bring a really own
brand onto the street and to
take on the role of founder that is
what really drove us there
and yes, that's why we think of it as our
own brand and do
exactly everything you said  you have
influenza marketing socially paid and all
the things to get the brand on the street,
various influencers too, then
they all come and now
someone else has a child, then
I get it sent by the car and then
so don’t push Lena Gercke and then the
third child  in one of your cars
through the area then we couldn't have given anything, we'd
like to try
to ask for something right away, okay, but I mean
that's the whole generation of
influencers, many who still have
children, then you still have real
potential,
exactly no, so we have a watch list
and all sorts of things, because it's clear
which influencers might be pregnant in the near future, yes, of
course, because you only have
a really mega short period in which
pregnancy becomes serious and
we already know that from ours
Manufacturers of baby buggies in particular
are filled up and then
of course to put the added value of our buggy to the
fore that is then
lost with the millions simply adding a buggy
that used to be the case with clothes
years ago it
might have been like that no well that  means you
really have to say okay, um
dear Lena, if you are in the car now, that
's quickly
worth 50-100 to you,
exactly how much then of course depends on
how much reach and the
influencer has, but absolutely that's
no longer possible  so easy but also to all
who are listening now you can just drive the car like that
no money for it if you have the better
looking and qualitatively and functionally
really best car or just get
in touch [laughter] brought digital industry into the company so the Johanneskirche too
before I was in the podcast,
um, I was selling socks with NOx
and it was very successful,
so I think the company will
then sell it directly for my
estimate, there are millions, um,
I’m not exactly sure about the numbers now,
but  well at least someone who is
always visible in the digital needs
how did it come about that they we
now want to build a modern young advisory board
you
exactly so we thought about if we
really want to raise the thing like a startup
and that in a
traditional company first  It's
difficult and it's more of a super
friendly environment to
found a startup, because of course with
capital from BabyOne, but also in an
environment where it's difficult to
find people who will challenge you, uh, who will
really push you hard
and give feedback on your
ideas and who have experience in
building startups and that's why we
put together an expert advisory board.
Johannes was there for a year, but he
left last year, um, because
he simply said that he did
n't think he was like that anymore
can bring a lot of added value to the product
Franziska von Hardenberg is in there
Markus Dietmann
Steffen is soft
exactly and Manuel Müller from Emma
emma is also a very so that’s
always a message in a bottle a few people the
story is really super cool and what we think of what
we learn from them
yes we had a meeting at the doctor last week
and we broke up so hard
but it's really awesome
I think it's um when they realize
that we think too much of BabyOne
and not
Elsa and Emil as our own  Brand see
then they intervene and then
they intervene strongly and then
they are absolutely right how much money do
you have to put into your hands what did
you finance it with the BabyOne capital
without investors but if you
would see it as independent and
would be now  if you
according to your business plan how much money
would have to shoot into it,
so first of all, you really financed it
from our capital as a family,
so that it can really be
seen as an independent company
and we have a small one
by the time we have the car on the road
seven-digit
amount
into the company exactly and that's where
we're going at the start oh really you can
do a baby carriage start-up so
compare independent apple if you founded it now
and I would say
I'm in the mood for it and have
no access to it in the industry we were
like that then  I can imagine building companies with a
few million but hardware
and we just don't know that ne so
you mustn't forget that because
we have the Baby one background ne
and we used the power of the system
just the
consultants ne of them
Areas that we have brought in with it
and the know-how that we have the
numbers and data and facts that we saw
like 35 years of Baby one are available
all the sales figures the figures about
what the stroller may cost or
not all of which we could
access that’s why it is  I do
n't think you should see it completely detached
but still it would somehow
I mean Johannes has already
left but as a big Amazon
propagandist but you still would
n't give it up so you say that even
though you might normally do it as an
entrepreneur
yes, we are convinced that
we are now also relying on the
BabyOne sales channel in particular because
that is exactly right, because it will
strengthen both systems and because we will also use it to
expand the brand
and Amazon and I think that
actually more is better  I
somehow said why not
do both,
so we'll start with the
sales channel BabyOne and the
chick and then we'll see from there, but
we also have to learn that it's also the
first brand that we really
have and we'll just take a look at it
first  and what is the other brand
that still exists there is another brand
called little one I think ne what
is like under what what again the
difference between BabyOne little one
and Emil and Elsa little one is more in the
price entry-level segment  on the way
and is actually the label here
we are with our old
own brand Bio, which is still in the
markets and it really has become a
classic retail brand with a
classic BabyOne reference
as a complete white label
solution and little one which system
accordingly further price entry
retail brand during  Parents
is price class and qualitatively and in
terms of sustainability just different
standard so has different
customer groups that we
can serve with it okay awesome so how much
if you can already build with in the end
the pool as a dealer of baby
I would have now yes I mean there is yes  if
you think about a quarter of a billion then
the other colleagues are much
bigger baby market and and and
if that's much bigger no in
here in Germany
Austria Switzerland we are the biggest
okay about a striking distance that
means you can see the entire market
then over a billion certainly
a small traders yes who really looks for the
singing market
for for the first four
years you are at about 5 billion
the market is big but as I said then
all the other
players come along like the drugstores etc who
also do a lot of the  Cakes, if at
all, come with
it, so you can get furniture from
us too, but of course you
can also buy them in large furniture stores at Ikea, you can also buy children’s beds, so
all of that is part of the overall
market volume and the whole area of
textiles also includes textures, what you have and how often
you probably have to buy new children's shoes
no that's all included in
the five billion
is
so easy your father
built it as a lifetime achievement is in
hindsight you have to say this company
is twice as big as e.g. Trigema I
would have the group are very visible  and
also very successful but sales he
your company is now almost exactly
twice as big
it was then also so that when
you grew up the
company was always there and he was really the
hardcore entrepreneur or is that
just sometimes you have it  Yes, that's how
I felt too. It's very,
very smooth. It's not like that for every
company. It's a tough battle,
it's just the
market behind you and then you have
relatively relaxed growth or
you're really the father every weekend
been on the phone
I think our parents
fought it a lot but otherwise actually
kept very much away from us so we did
n't notice that much at the dinner table or when we were at home we
also heard that we were
opening a few new markets or
taken over yes and then we
dealt with other topics
you also felt a
normal life you were I think a
four weeks or how much we
New Zealand six weeks ago with the family and
something that sounds quite relaxed
considering that we definitely founded the whole thing
that's the nice thing that we
do it as a couple, that we can
really share one another at such points,
that it's possible and
the topics that we set ourselves years ago
as a family that we
can also pull through, that's nice and
ok  okay um I'm curious who knows
[music]
already researched in Hamburg the
next market here it's at least from
our headquarters isn't that
close at all so half an hour so done
I'm not sure but won't
be the next time but maybe
in the online shop then it's probably
when a lot of people
say okay so when is it coming that the
car is coming in April that's like 13.04
so somehow keep the kids
in your stomach for a while
in April
and if you report anything you need again
You
post somehow
everything clear thank you very much